when I am
performing I am nothing but
[Applause]
free is it
recording the goal for this tour was to
create a place where everyone is
free and no one is
judged you
unique
you stand by for prop
down dogs in
light start over start fresh create the
[Music]
new that's what the Renaissance is
about
everyone welcome to Mother's mind
we dress a certain way we walk a certain
way we talk a certain way we paint a
certain way we we make love a certain
way at any point they could close their
eyes and be right back there and take it
with
himing to the system we flying over we
flying over Supernatural love
affili what do you think about this to I
feel liberated I have transitioned into
a new
[Music]
animal all of these things we do in a
different unique specific
way